hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
network delay time the reason i'm
solving this problem is because it's a
rare problem that you actually have to
use
ajixtra's however you pronounce that
name
this algorithm it's the shortest path
algorithm
it's not super common on leak code but i
think it's a really cool
problem to solve a cool algorithm to
implement so obviously this is a graph
problem we're given
a network of n nodes labeled from
1 to n and we're also given a list of
times the times are going to be our
edges so
it's going to be directed edges so a
time
is a triple value the first value in
this triple
is going to be the source node so for
example this node 2
the second node the second value is
going to be the target
node for example 1 is this node
and the reason it's a target is we can
see that there is an
outgoing edge going from two to the one
so every edge is going to be directed
right we can see there's a directed edge
there a directed edge here
the third value and this is also pretty
important for this algorithm
is the weight of the edge in the context
of this problem the one basically just
means the amount of time
it's going to take for us to go from
here to this node right
but this is the weight of the edge so
we're given
a original node k so this is our
starting point the node k is going to be
the starting point
so for example in this problem in this
origin in this graph
we're given k equals 2. that means this
is the starting point
for us what we want to do in this
problem
is starting at two how
long would it take for us to visit
every single node basically if we
if we sent a signal from here in every
direction so in this direction
and in this direction how long would it
take for that signal to reach
every single node now if it's not
possible for example
in this case it is possible but what if
we had a fifth node over here
that's just not connected to these four
nodes over here then it would be
impossible
for this node to send a signal here in
that case
we're simply going to return negative
one because it's not possible
but what about in this problem because
it is possible
how long is it going to take that's the
only question now looking at the picture
it's pretty obvious
starting at 2 how long is it going to
take for this to reach a signal
it's going to take 1 right because the
weight of the edge
is 1. how long is it going to take for
this node to
to get the signal also one because
the the weight of the edge is one so now
we're over here
let me just change the color to make it
a little bit better by the way this was
the original node how long did it take
this node to get the signal
technically zero right because it's the
one sending the signal
how long did it take this three to reach
the signal one
how long did it take this to reach a
signal one now we're going to continue
going
from this three we know that this one
doesn't have any more nodes that it can
send the signal to but this three
does it has a node over here four right
now how long is it going to take this
four to reach the signal
well the weight of the edge is one so
does that mean it's going to take
the for one second or whatever our time
unit is to reach this
no because we have to add the one from
over here right
remember our signal first started over
here
then it traveled over here with one then
it's going to travel again
over here with one so in total once we
have visited this
node it's going to have taken two units
of time to reach it
now after this node reaches gets the
signal
that means everybody has gotten the
signal how long did it take what's the
largest value we have
it took this one right this one took two
seconds or whatever
so therefore we're going to return two
because after
two you know units of time every node
has received the signal so our output
value
in this case is going to be 2. now from
looking at this example that we ran
through you might be able to tell that
jigstr's algorithm is actually a breadth
first search algorithm
that i'm going to show you the general
idea of
but the one difference about regular
breadth for searches
this algorithm actually uses a minimum
heap
aka a priority queue so we're going to
be needing this data structure it's not
a super common data structure
but it is it is needed for this graph
algorithm let me show you the actual
algorithm after that we're going to jump
into the code
so in case you want to google this
algorithm or do some more research it is
called
jigsaw's algorithm it is a shortest path
graph algorithm
and it's pretty common you have probably
learned it in school if you study cs
and what it does is in this case let's
say our source or our starting point is
this node the value one what it does
is for every other node it basically
tells you the shortest path right so
for example three what's the length of
the shortest path
to this node well from directly from one
to three
it takes one so one is going to be the
shortest path
for this node what about this two node
what's the shortest path to this node
right
with this it's pretty obvious because
there's only one
way to get here anyway but take a look
at this node
there's two different ways to get there
now this
is this the shortest path it's the
obvious path right it's just
one node away but the edge has a weight
of four that's a problem because take a
look at the second path that we can do
we can go to
three right over here then we can go to
the four
and then we can get to the two right
that took three
edges didn't it that took one edge two
edge
three edges but when we total these
values up
we get a sum of three that means
this path is actually shorter than the
path up here so
it's not always clear right that's why
we need an algorithm
and that's exactly what we have we have
jigsaw's algorithm
and we're going to be doing a breath
first search right so starting at this
node the start node 1 we're only going
to be possibly visiting nodes that are
that are right next to our frontier
right
depth first search would be we just go
one direction we just keep going right
but breadth first search
is we're gonna do this layer by layer
right we're going to go to the first
layer
the next layer and so on if we had a
bigger graph right that's how breadth
first search works
and every node that is on our
frontier right so if this is our
starting point we have two
options of nodes we can visit this node
or this node
these both are going are going to be
added to our min
heap and we're only going to visit the
one with a shorter path
that does make sense so far doesn't it
it makes sense that we would want to
visit
this node because it has a shorter path
rather than visiting this node first
which has a longer path right that makes
sense so far
that's why we're using a minimum heap
minimum heaps can get us the minimum
value
pretty efficiently right every time we
want to get a minimum value from the min
heap
it's just a log n operation
okay so the way we initialize this
algorithm is we know that we're starting
here right what we're going to actually
do
is add this node to our min heap
initially right so
and in our min heap we're going to be
keeping track of two values
obviously the path length right because
we're always going to be popping
from the min heap based on the minimum
path right so that's what
that's like our key value that's what we
actually care about right that's what's
going to determine
which one we pop but we also want to
keep track of which node it is right so
initially
the path to reach uh the initial node
one
is zero right because we're that's where
we're starting so
it doesn't cost us anything to get there
and the node itself
is obviously one so this is how we're
gonna start then we're gonna pop
this value it's only one value so far so
it's it's simple
of where we're popping right once we pop
this value
what's our next step well like i said
this is a
breadth first search right so we're
gonna take a look at the node over here
it's one we're gonna look at all of its
neighbors right
it has two neighbors right we're
checking that first
layer this we're going we're going layer
by layer
with breadth first search right so this
is our first layer right
we're gonna take the first neighbor
three how long does it take to reach
three one
we're not visiting it yet we're simply
adding it to
our min heap so the path length is one
and this is for node three then other
node that we can reach
is two the path length is four let's add
that
as well four and the node is two
and since we've already visited the node
one we can cross it out now
so now we're popping another value this
time we have two values so which one are
we gonna pop well this is a min heap
right we're gonna pop the value with the
minimum
path it's this one right of course
that's the one with the shortest path
that's what we're gonna pop
now so as we pop every element
we're basically determining the minimum
path so now we can say for sure that the
minimum path to reach three
takes us one right because one was the
value that we added
to our min heap and again we're just
doing a breath first search
what are all of the nodes that three has
neighbors with
it it only has neighbors with one node
right this four we have a directed edge
going exactly to four so let's add
four to our min heap
so we're adding the node 4 right so
that's what we're going to put in the
node position
what are we going to put in the path
position are we just going to put
1 because it only takes 1 for us to get
there from
3 that's not actually what we're going
to put we're going to take
the total that it took to reach three
which was
one and it's taking us another one
to reach four so we're gonna add the
total to this right we're not just
keeping track of the single one
we're keeping track of the total path it
takes
for each node we want to know how long
it takes to reach node 4
all the way from our starting position
we care about the starting position so
when i put the path value
of the path length for this node i'm
going to put a 2 value
so now we are once again done with this
node so now again we are going to decide
which one are we going to pop
from our min heap we want to pop the
value with a
shorter path so we're going to pop this
one
so now we're at this node right and how
many nodes can this node
reach well it only has a single outgoing
edge
to this node 2 right and we see that
2 has actually already been added to
our min heap right but the only
difference is this time
and i'm running out of space so i'm just
going to add a little slot is that
for this 2 it's how long
first of all how long did it take to
reach this it took a distance of
two to reach this four and plus one
means that to reach this to reach this
two now it's actually a distance of 3
which is
shorter than this one right so now
we can actually add that same node 2
to our min heap but this time we're
going to have
a distance of 3 which is shorter so we
visited this node
and now you can see that we only have
one node remaining to visit
good thing for us both of our options in
the
min heap lead to that node which one are
we gonna pick
it's a min heap so we're gonna pick this
one 3
is less than 4 so we're going to pop
this from our min heap
so now we finally popped the last node
it's a path length of
3 so now that we've reached every single
node in our array and by the way this
node does not have any outgoing edges so
we don't have to do anything more
and we even though we do have an a value
left in our min heap
once we pop it we're going to see that
it's the same node that we've already
visited we visited this two node and we
visited every node now and you can see
the max
value that we got in terms of length is
three
so three is going to be our output in
this case it takes
three units of time or whatever for us
to start at this
position and then send a signal to every
other node
in the graph so analyzing the time
complexity of this problem is actually a
little more difficult than you think so
i'm going to use
e to tell us basically the number of
total edges
inside of our graph that we're given
and v for the total number of nodes or
vertices that we're given
and just so you know the maximum number
of edges
that we could possibly have is about
proportional to the number
of nodes squared because like it's just
kind of how it works so like if we had
two nodes
or rather three nodes you know there's
we could have bi-directional edges
for every pair of nodes and if you just
basically this is just something that's
true and that's what i'm going to assume
so the max size of our heap could
actually be
v squared even though we have let's say
four
edges we noticed that some of the uh
or rather we have four nodes we notice
that some of the nodes could be added
into the min heap
multiple times that's dependent on the
total number of edges that's why we're
saying v
squared is the total number of nodes
that could be in the heap
so every heap operation is possibly
worst case
log v squared and how many times
are we going to be doing this operation
it's going to be e
times worst case basically the number of
edges because for every edge
is how many times we can add values to
the heap
right so and this and the way logs work
logarithms if you take this 2 we can
actually
get rid of that too put it over here
right put the two over here and we know
how big o
complexity works we don't care about
constant values
so this two actually goes away so the
overall
big o time complexity with a
priority queue for a jigsaw's algorithm
is going to be e
log v this is just the general overview
now let's get into the code
so we're actually given a list of edges
and we want to create an adjacency list
of that first
for jigsaw's algorithm so the first
thing i'm going to do is create a
dictionary or a hashmap of
edges initially it's just going to be an
empty list
so i'm going to go through every edge in
the input
so for so for every edge u i'm going to
get a list of all of its
uh neighbors right because we know that
that's pretty useful for a gixxer's
algorithm we're going to
basically get every single outgoing
neighbor so v
is the neighbor node and w is the weight
of that node so we're going to add that
to edges
list for you so this is just creating an
adjacency list for us which is going to
be useful
now i'm going to create that min heap we
remember
we want to just initialize this min heap
with the first value and the
weight of it's going to be 0 because we
know it doesn't cost us anything to get
there and that
starting node is given to us as k i'm
also going to have one more data
structure it's going to be a set
basically it's going to keep track of
all the nodes that we've visited because
we know we don't want to go
in a cycle we don't want to go in a loop
so we do have to
sort of keep track of that i'm also
going to have a variable t
for the result initially it's going to
be 0 basically the max
value that we end up getting or the last
node that we visit
and the cost or the length to visit that
note is going to be the value that we
return
so now we're just going to continue our
algorithm while our min heap
is non-empty we're going to keep popping
from
our heap while it's not empty we know
that there's two values that we added
the
weight was the first value the second
was the actual node itself so we're
going to say
keep q dot heap pop
from our min heap this is basically how
you do it in python it's
pretty easy in python that's what i like
and
like i said we don't want to visit a
node multiple times so if we see that
this node
n1 is in visit meaning it's already been
visited then we're just going to
continue to the next
iteration of the loop we don't want to
go through all of this node's neighbors
if it's already been visited otherwise
what we're going to do is
add it to visit so that we don't visit
it again and we're also going to update
our result
t so we're going to set it to the max of
what it already is
and the max of the weight that we just
got the weight is remember the time it
takes to reach
this node so we're going to update that
now we're going to do the breath first
search
portion of it so we're going to go
through all the neighbors
of this node so the no the neighbor and
the neighbor's
weight so i'm just going to call that n2
and w2 because i'm bad at naming
these so in edges basically neighbors
of this n1 original node that we just
popped from
our min heap we're going to go through
it and for all of the neighbors that
haven't already been visited so if
n2 is not in visit it's it has not been
visited yet
then we're going to add it to our min
heap so heap q dot
heap push on to our min heap
is going to be this node n2
but remember the first value we're
adding is the weight so
weight 2 but remember this weight
is just this weight 2 is just the weight
that it takes
for one edge but we want to keep track
of the total
uh path length to reach this node so
we're actually going to add that
w1 the first weight to it
as well so w1 plus w2
the total path that it takes to reach n2
i know that this algorithm is actually
pretty complicated
it's not a lot of code it's about 20
lines but it's actually
you know it does take some practice to
get used to it after you've written it a
few times you do kind of understand the
subtleties of it
it's pretty easy to go wrong with this
algorithm but we've basically
written the entire thing so now we can
return
t after this loop is done executing
after the min heap is empty
our t should give us the uh basically
what it takes to reach every single node
if it's possible right remember if it's
possible
and we know that it's possible basically
we've visited
every single node if the length of visit
is equal
to our input value n which tells us the
total number of nodes if we visited
every node then we can return
t remember the other condition was if we
can't visit every single node
we return negative one and that is the
entire algorithm remember the overall
time complexity is big
o the total number of edges multiplied
by log the total number of vertices
so this was a pretty long one it was
pretty difficult i actually had a lot of
bugs when i was writing my code for this
video
and i hope that this came across pretty
clear
if this was helpful please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching